c'est l'heure de la chronique culture
sortaient des fils jonah me rejoint au
pas de course bonsoir je n a pas manqué
de galanterie mais vous avez un bal à
tous je viens du cirque bouglione qu'un
style à plaisir mais on en parlera à la
semaine la semaine prochaine cette fois
ci nous parlons du festival orphée ça
c'est du teasing
ah oui ça c'est du théâtre on veut
revoir avec ce nez rouge alors on porte
du festival orphée soutenir oui cette
année ils fêtent leurs 10 ans une
édition spéciale qui s'ouvre avec une
compagnie espagnole vendredi 28
septembre dans quelques jours au théâtre
montansier alors ce spectacle de danse
dont j'espère qu'on pourra voir quelques
images est interprétée par la compagnie
flic floc d'annezin et dont la moitié
des artistes est atteinte d'un handicap
physique ou mental
alors certaines personnes sont voyante
d'autres hyper active ou ou épileptique
par exemple lancé ce spectacle qui va
ouvrir la voie là c'est le premier
spectacle des neuf spectacles programmés
au total dans ce festival un festival
qui s'annonce émouvant parce que bien
soufflé dix bougies c'est une belle
récompense et puis ce sera l'occasion
pour michel reynaud de tirer sa
révérence voilà celle 1 donc on avait
déjà reçu ce prix qui est un homme aux
multiples casquettes
oui alors d'une part il est le directeur
artistique du festival le festival
orphée et d'autre part il est aussi le
directeur artistique du théâtre
eurydice à plaisir le théâtre rue 17,1
esat un établissement et service dette
au travail pour les personnes
handicapées
chaque année bien sûr la compagnie
théâtre eurydice participe au festival
orphée et cette année comme je disais
michel reynaud annoncera son départ du
théâtre eurydice dont il est le
fondateur
il va complètement coupé les ponts avec
le festival non pas avec le festival je
vous rassure il quittera seulement
plaisir il reste aux commandes du
festival orphée sur versailles un
festival dont il est également à
l'origine nous avons rencontré justement
michel reynaud et nous explique comment
il organisait son départ j'ai tout fait
pour juste
comment ne pas partir brutalement donc
je me suis arrangé qu'on association
pour laisser la main sur les deux ans
qui qui sont passés là pour justement
permettre au projet de s'équilibrer que
les gens ici s'habitue à voir de moins
en moins parce que j'en ai une attache
évidemment effective énorme
orphée par contre je vais continuer donc
il y aura ce lien toujours avec cette
partie de ce travail
et puis peut-être sur le plan du travail
artistique avec des personnes
handicapées j'aurais peut-être des
propositions de gens qui voudront que je
viens de faire une mise en scène ou d
une écriture puisque j'ai cette
compétence depuis tant d'années michel
reynaud met donc en scène pour la
dernière fois ses comédiens handicapés
au tâtre eurydice avec une adaptation
des exercices de style de raymond
queneau et joue avec des comédiens non
handicapés de la compagnie art théâtre
c'est ça aussi l'objectif du festival
orphée ne pas faire de différence
défendre avec avant tout l'artiste qui
sommeille en chacun
je suis très fier de finir d'ailleurs et
que pour aurélie c'est en tout cas avec
ce spectacle là parce que c'est la
synthèse de toutes mes 40 ans de travail
de dire on peut travailler avec des
personnes handicapées et faire un
travail professionnel de qualité et
c'est aussi le but du festival orphée
donc de finir avec ce spectacle avec ses
deux troupes qui jouent ensemble
c'est pour moi un énorme symbole de 42
ans de
de combat parce que c'est aussi un
combat contre contre la bêtise contre
l'élitisme content parce que dans le
milieu du théâtre en plus culturelle en
général les gens défendent les causes
mais en même temps il exclut tout le
monde alors c'est assez la contradiction
on m'a toujours fasciné alors justement
- grâce à ce travail ce métier que j'ai
pu faire
j'ai mis en adéquation ce qui la rend
souvent dans la défense des causes
perdues et justement avec des gens dont
on dit que la cause est perdue
c'est ça aussi la grande force croix du
projet eurydice et d'orphée aussi ses
dettes
dans la réalité on fait avec les gens
n'assiste pas les gens fait avec eux on
entendu le directeur artistique du
festival
est-ce que vous avez rencontrées aussi
les comédiens sur une répétition nous
leur avons demandé quel était leur
vision du théâtre ensemble
je trouve ça se passe bien il n'y a pas
de difficultés particulières
c'est une organisation du travail qui
est très légèrement différente mais mais
à peine donc on joue
les répétitions sont un petit peu
organisés différemment c'est simplement
mais ce qui est important c'est le
travail travail final les faits par
curiosité au départ et on ne connaît
bien une chose que lorsqu'on la vie
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on en fait l'expérience
et moi je trouve c'est une expérience
très enrichissante sur le plan personnel
comme le disait monde si j'ai besoin de
reconnaissance donc c'est important
qu'ils ça m'a permis au début de sortie
de l'intimité parce que j'étais très
timide et puis ça me parle il prend
confiance en moi aussi et puis ça m'a
permis de oc d'être à plusieurs années
ce qui est génial quoi et puis ça a une
certaine fierté puisque à venger des
handicapés pour un trail et le fait
d'être en ct ou s'est aménagé ou en plus
j'ai des coups j'ai fait du théâtre ce
qui ma passion c'est aussi impressionné
j'ai beaucoup le trac et puis j'ai
toujours le trac avant qui va c'est
encore plus impressionnant parce que
avec la salle les spectateurs dans de
spectateurs c'est impressionnant c c'est
en ces gens sont avec tous les gens qui
sont là qui applaudissent
c'est vraiment un beau moment joue le
rôle du commissaire qui interviewent
c'est un troisième scène gpat exit où je
suis en costume comme l'a déjà incarné
avec un crayon et je fais l'inspecteur
qui note comme si l'interview les gens
et à regarder la mer s'il consomme et
puis notez que comme ça et donc l'âge et
toute la scène suis tout le temps debout
puis je vais de personne en personne à
qui je fais ce col mais bien tassée et
qu'ils ont notamment fait hongrie oui
parce que s'il n'y a pas assez de zinc à
part ça je préférais
c'est
peut-être
j'aime bien le précieux à la fin j'ai
une longue tirade cgg indigènes texte
c'est un personnage de paul à peu faire
nous parlons nous parlons ce soir du
festival orphée festival théâtre et
handicap
un rappel des dates jaune vendredi 28
septembre donc lancement avec le
spectacle de danse de la compagnie
espagnole au théâtre montansier et le
lendemain samedi 29 à 20h30 toujours au
théâtre montansier les exercices de
style de raymond queneau que l'on vient
d'apercevoir un autre coup de coeur
peut-être sur ce festival oui je
voudrais vous parler de miro c'est un
artiste original comme vous voudrez en
voir plus souvent
comme son nom l'indiqué miro est aveugle
il a progressivement perdu la vue il y a
dix huit ans à cause d'une
dégénérescence de la rétine
souvent quand j'allais quelque part
malgré moi ce que je disais ça faisait
raya faisait pas pourquoi donc ma
manière de présenter les choses
et puis avec mon premier chien l'hymne
est arrivé des choses pas possible et
moi je racontais ça pour peu
vider un peu mon sac quoi et en fait les
gens c'est moins de profs et c'était pas
drôle quoi c'était des choses qui
m'arrivait moi je trouve ça un peu
dramatique est en fait après vous dirais
tu devrais tu aurait créé un spectale en
fait mureaux était kinésithérapeute et
lorsqu'il a perdu la vue et bien ça a
été très difficile pour lui d'accepter
cette situation de handicap
mais lorsqu'il y est parvenu eh bien il
s'est lancé dans le théâtre il a
commencé les cours simon et les cours
florent aussi ensuite il s'est jeté sur
scène pour son spectacle je te lis tous
les autres élèves
et puis quand j'avais des banques parce
que je lis pas ce qui se passait mal se
demandait quand décrivent ce qui se
passe voilà éventuellement toucher
positionnement oui il y avait une
en fait c'est un mélange de beaucoup de
choses mélange du reste de ma vie que
j'avais encore à l'époque
et puis quand j'avais besoin des
descriptions d'ailleurs ça existe quand
des aveugles vont au théâtre il ya ce
qu'on appelle l'audiodescription c'est à
dire on a un casque est quelqu'un nous
décrit ce qu'on peut pas comprendre avec
le son c'est ça qui est bien avec miro
c'est que ben on apprend beaucoup de
choses avec lui sa volonté de faire rire
bien sûr mais en même temps d'apprendre
des choses sur l'univers des personnes
mal ou non voyantes son spectacle
s'adresse cependant à tous on peut
apprendre ou bien se retrouver dans les
histoires
j'explique en fait comment ça se passe
avec un chien et puis après comment ça
se passe avec une canne et après ça
c'est comment ça se passe quand on est
mal voyants mais tout ça en fait c'est
pédagogique instructif jeu à prendre le
bus c'est hongrie pas pour rire mais
henry pour apprendre fait je me sers du
rire comme moyen d'apprentissage
donc en fait tout est accessible tout le
monde peut comprendre même si on n'est
pas dans le milieu
à la fin si vous avez pris des notes
vous avez appris beaucoup de choses mais
vous avez passé surtout un bon moment
c'est ça mon but c'est un peu j'essaie
de mon niveau 1 de faire un nouveau
style doux
cette sorte d'humour moore pédagogique
je commande pourrait dire mon but c'est
que les gens apprennent plus mais on
s'amuse en apprendre plus en s'amusant
est ce que tout est vrai dans ce
festival dans ce spectacle parle
pratiquement tous miro précise au public
un lorsque ce sont des histoires un
petit peu inventé le dis je rigole mais
sinon il s'inspire tout à fait de sa vie
privée de ce qui lui arrive et on va
justement urbain mais voilà avec une
petite mésaventure qui lui est arrivée
avec son chien son chien guide
le problème c'est que mon chien il a une
carte d'identité ce que les chiens
guides vous savez il peut aller partout
il va dans l'avion en cabine s'il vous
plaît allez à l'hôtel il peut aller dans
le taxi
il peut aussi passer les frontières pour
passer les frontières dont il a besoin
d'une carte d'identité et sa carte
d'identité
au toucher elle est exactement comme ma
carte d'invalidité
elle a le même format avec la photo en
bas à gauche avec les deux petits points
sont
je fouille dans mon sac je crois
reconnaître ma carte d'invalidité
je la prends et je la donne à la dame
qu'est ce que vous m'auriez des vous
vous êtes trompés vous m'avez donné la
carte de votre chien et elle mais c'est
pas moi sur la photo comme moi c'est une
vieille carte si vous voulez j'ai pas
fait refaire ça fait 20 ans que je lai
je me suis dit elle m'a pas reconnue je
lui dis c'est moi mais j'étais plus
jeune je revenais de vacances mais on va
se produire donc à la royale factory de
mardi 16 octobre à 20h30
je vous propose tout de suite de
découvrir un dernier extrait où l'on
apprend comment fonctionne une canne
blanche
le mec il m'attrape par le bout de la
canne allez monsieur on va monter dans
le métro dans une folle faut savoir qu'à
l'intérieur de laquelle il ya un gros
caoutchouc qui réunit les quatre
morceaux entre m le mec était déjà dans
le métro moi j'y vais toujours sur le
quai et la cades va longer s'allonge
elle allongée et chef d'astiz à l'esma
pourra remonter dans le métro là une
fois là ce que je vais pas pouvoir
continuer à tirer sur l'élastique encore
extrait du spectacle de miro donc que
johanna vous nous avez vendu ce soir et
qu'on a qu'une envie maintenant c'est
d'aller voir avant de se quitter très
rapidement pour cette chronique culture
une annonce de concert oui c'est demain
soir toujours à la ruelle factory de
versailles un groupe qui nous vient de
chez nous mord pas et rap il s'appelle
lily sofa et on va écouter tout de suite
un extrait de leur chanson mais big is
the one
m
non
à
merci donc à johanna pour cette
chronique culture et pas merci pour ce
morceau c'était pas vous forcer mais ça
aurait pu tout à fait dans la rédaction
des fois où on va prendre votre guitare
comme ça chaque mercredi nous allons à
la rencontre des spectateurs à la sortie
des salles de cinéma et la guitare pour
nous encourager à les ranger votre
guitare janin on part à la sortie des
salles des cinémas de saint quentin en
yvelines pour recueillir vos réactions à
l'issue des premières projections les
sorties ciné o les sans voix
j'ai mené mais super joueur sympathique
un bien ou fines et j'ai mon fils est
fan de foot et en plus c'est une réunion
de pas mal d'acteurs comiques que on les
voit jenny pour la première fois pour
certains donc c'est vraiment un très bon
feeling très plaisant seigneur c'était
sympa grève en vue les seigneurs et
voilà moi j'aime pas le foot ma copine
non plus mais même si on n'aime pas le
foot les filles faut y aller parce que
c'est sympa il ya une jolie feinte passe
un bon moment
il ya d'émotion aussi on rigole et puis
il ya jean pierre marielle
oh la la qu'est ce qu'il est bon ce papy
jade pas si mal que ça ça va serait bien
bon c'était pas le meilleur mais ça a
été quand même une jolie feinte laval
afin laisse penser à une suite mais
après il faut voir ce que ça donne
le président thé ville ce n'était pas
terrible resident evil
c'était un super film en 3d avec c'est
un super film voit la super film
d'action très bon film et et on attend
la suite avec impatience